[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de france 24 que los invitaron a vuelta
al mundo de la mano de nuestra red de
periodistas seguimos enfocados en la
guerra de ucrania que sigue cobrando
vidas y avivando una crisis de
refugiados que acnur ya ha calificado
como la peor desde la segunda guerra
mundial mujeres niños y ancianos
intentan salir mientras que los hombres
de entre 18 a 60 años deben quedarse en
el país por una ley marcial que nos
obliga a defender a su patria informe de
nuestra corresponsal irene sabio
con el estallido de la guerra de rusia
en ucrania andrei se unió a las unidades
territoriales de defensa un cuerpo de
milicianos ucranianos que son parte de
la resistencia contra la agresión rusa
estoy en mi tierra por eso no tengo
miedo en lo que piensas en los rusos
se pregunta difícil para mí mi papá
nació en rusia mi mamá nació en belarús
conozco a mucha gente en rusia son gente
buena es putin que quiere la guerra
mucho mucho en juego
andrei cuenta aquí pasa hasta 14 horas
en los check point in fundando un call
ha sido y controlando que el resto de
los milicianos hagan bien su trabajo
cuál es el problema quieren matarme a mí
a mi familia a mis amigos y nos quieren
despojar de una parte importante de mi
país
mientras el ejército ucraniano se
encuentra en la primera línea de batalla
estos civiles luchan en la retaguardia
levantando barricadas y checkpoint que
sirven para controlar a todos aquellos
que entran y salen de las ciudades
rusia es una guerra no una guerra solo
contra ucrania es una guerra contra
todos los países europeos y todos los
países del mundo el robot el coronel
alexandr no quiere que se diga su
apellido y explica que centenares de
civiles armados bajo su mando tenemos
que defendernos somos hombres y tenemos
que hacer todo lo que podamos para
defendernos pero cuando le preguntamos
si tiene miedo de morir el coronel es
contundente no no tengo miedo de morir
a medida que las tropas rusas se acercan
a quien las poblaciones aledañas se
convierten en focos de conflicto no es
el caso de ir ping a unos 25 kilómetros
al noroeste de la capital ucraniana allí
los bombardeos han alcanzado a la
población civil mientras tanto en la
capital tantos soldados como ciudadanos
se enfrentan a la perspectiva de una
embestida por parte de las tropas de
moscú el siguiente es un reportaje de 12
odiah big bueno bien y sólo nos musa
el futuro es incierto el frente de
batalla no está lejos pero el amor como
la guerra está por todas partes para
alicia y valerie es ahora o nunca para
casarse ciudadanos de a pie hace apenas
dos semanas ahora están listos para
defender kiev pero antes portando sus
uniformes militares y cascos durante la
ceremonia ortodoxa hay que celebrar la
unión yo alicia te tomo como mi esposo
te prometo amor y fidelidad hasta que la
muerte nos separe
los declaro marido y mujer los
felicitamos puedes besar a la novia
la alegría es pasajera en una ciudad que
se ha transformado por completo las
intersecciones de las carreteras son
ahora puestos de control los sacos de
arena se amontonan como barreras contra
los tanques rusos
ya estamos acostumbrados a esta
situación alrededor de kiev hay combates
pero estamos preparados para resistir
a sólo 20 km de la capital en el
suburbio de irbin murieron el domingo
varios civiles entre ellos una familia
con dos niños cuando intentaban huir
en los bombardeos de artillería
alcanzaron toda la ciudad los suburbios
las casas particulares los apartamentos
estábamos bajo tierra pero era una
oportunidad para escapar así que cogimos
nuestro equipaje y vinimos aquí en coche
y el hámster es que puentes bombardeados
cuerpos en medio de la carretera
animales en los brazos de quienes dejan
sus hogares los habitantes de irving
huyen de los combates mientras la caída
de las bombas rusas se acerca a la
capital
en el calendario cristiano ortodoxo el
domingo es el día del perdón sin embargo
muchos de los ucranianos que han sufrido
las consecuencias de esta invasión rusa
dicen que ya no pueden perdonar nuestro
corresponsal weaver crack de nuestra
cadena hermana en inglés nos envió el
siguiente reporte desde el abismo en la
principal ciudad en el occidente de
ucrania que se ha convertido en
epicentro de la llegada de miles de
personas que quieren salir del país y
buscar refugio en otras naciones de
europa
este teatro infantil del leaf es ahora
una residencia para desplazados internos
y le habla de están ayudando
ambos originarios de mariupol no saben
nada de sus familias desde hace 4 días
no sabemos si tienen comida o agua o
electricidad o incluso si están vivos es
realmente una sensación terrible cuando
ves la foto de un cadáver y piensas
genial no es un conocido pero nos
alegramos cuando matan a soldados rusos
y así será hasta que se vayan
[Música]
estos amigos actores de profesión
acabaron en el teatro ofreciendo
consejos y vigilando a los impostores
hola
está registrada
registrada donde en el interior mujeres
y niños que huyeron de otras partes de
ucrania no tiene ni idea de lo que les
depara el futuro
cómo podremos perdonarlos por esto no no
existe tal perdón por supuesto que no
nunca hoy en día muchos reconstruyen los
crímenes del régimen soviético como
crímenes de los rusos contra los
ucranianos murcia su creencia fiesta
cada historia 32 los ucranianos pueden
encontrar una historia si repasan su
árbol genealógico de algún miembro que
fue ejecutado y los que recuerdan esto
saben que no se puede esperar nada bueno
de los rusos ucranianos saben muy bien
que la mayoría de los rusos no han
asistido a las protestas contra la
guerra bueno
no podemos perdonar a los rusos por su
silencio el silencio es complicidad en
la agresión todo esto en pleno domingo
del perdón del calendario cristiano
ortodoxo
[Música]
pero según el padre andrew de esta
iglesia de los suburbios del live no hay
necesidad de perdonar a putin
crisis post ahora ya sé cómo
justo por russo y este reto está en el
libro de deuteronomio maldito sea el que
viola el territorio de su vecino no
podemos rezar por el pueblo ruso como
pueblo perdido pero no por los que
dirigen esta guerra no dios no lo
permita
a menos de dos semanas de la completa
invasión de rusia en ucrania ya es claro
que los lazos entre estos dos países
están rotos por generaciones por
degeneración
de los países de américa latina ecuador
era el que tenía la comunidad más
numerosa en ucrania con aproximadamente
800 personas el ministro de relaciones
exteriores de ese país juan carlos
holguín aseguró que más de 700 ya han
abandonado ucrania mientras muchos se
debaten entre sí regresar a ecuador o
dirigirse a la unión europea
451 ecuatorianos lograron regresar a su
nación a bordo de dos vuelos
humanitarios y la historia nos la trae
nuestro corresponsal de gustavo ortega
danny está a la espera del regreso de
sus hijos desde ucrania las habitaciones
están intactas desde hace tres años
cuando daniela y sebastián se fueron a
estudiar ingeniería aeronáutica al país
ubicado al este de europa ahora han
emprendido el retorno huyendo de la
guerra la decisión que hemos tomado como
familia de que ellos vuelvan y que
danielle específicamente vuelva ya
estando por cumplir tres años allá en su
carrera de ingeniería de aviación es
simplemente para una tranquilidad y
obtener en ellos y recuperar en ellos
una paz mental y psicológica que debe
estar afectada danny visita a diario la
cancillería ecuatoriana en búsqueda de
información se encuentra con más padres
que desean traer a sus hijos de vuelta
para alejarlos del conflicto entre rusia
y ucrania
leonel es otro padre preocupado recibe
una llamada de su hijo ha logrado llegar
a varsovia pero las noticias no son del
todo buenas como padre el dolor es
grande pero yo le comento que mi hijo no
regresa adecuados él no va a regresar al
ecuador
desde una sala de atención improvisada
la cancillería rastrea satelitalmente
los ecuatorianos e intenta convencerlos
de abordar un vuelo humanitario con
espacio para 350 con nacionales
recibimos muchísimos pedidos de que se
puedan quedar en españa o en italia les
quiero les quiero decir de corazón que
regresa en ecuador que les pidan que les
aconsejen y poder anunció que no podrá
otorgar visas para estadía en un país
europeo por ello usted va prefiere
salvarse de la tierra y huir a su país
no hay comida
y
aquí están los documentos de vuelta en
casa se inicia para certificar la
nacionalidad de sus hijos quienes no
regresen en este avión están obligados a
firmar un acuerdo de responsabilidad
antes ecuatoriano por permanecer de
manera irregular
en la unión europea
cada tradición trae sus particularidades
en la capital española cada miércoles de
ceniza después del carnaval una
procesión funeraria en tono burlón y de
parodia recorre las calles de madrid
este año la guerra se hizo presente con
las acciones y pensamientos que fueron
quemados como parte de este entierro
simbólico nuestra corresponsal marina
colorado nos explica en qué consiste el
entierro de la sardina una tradición
llena de historia y de leyenda que se
celebra hace más de 250 años
nazaret la sardina
y
así inicia el funeral más alegre de
españa'
como lo hicieron cada miércoles de
ceniza generaciones anteriores jesús
junto con sus compañeros de cofradía
carga con el ataúd de la protagonista de
este entierro una sardina el reírnos un
poco de la institución y que no los
unidades no tienen por qué ser porque
ser triste
un entierro simbólico que en madrid se
remonta al siglo 18
este pueblo de madrid tenía una gran
hambruna entonces en esa época mandó
traer dado que quedaba a la que empezaba
a la cuaresma mandó traer un cargamento
de sardinas que vino de santander y vino
como vino es decir llegó muy malamente
cómodamente y entonces el pueblo decidió
que con chanzas
risas y bailes enterrar ese desastre que
había llegado
para jesús formar parte de la alegre
cofradía del entierro de la sardina es
una manera de honrar la historia de la
ciudad que le acogió este pequeño museo
con los distintos
ataúdes de todos los años que hemos
podido conservar en definitiva que es lo
de conservar las tradiciones y tratar de
transmitir las pues es por eso para
nosotros es muy importante que no caiga
en el olvido porque las cosas que caen
en el olvido se acaban olvidando
borrando
y de lo que no tengamos memoria no queda
historia no queda nada
cae la noche en madrid y se encienden
las antorchas un fuego que sirve para
que jesús y el resto de madrileños
puedan pedir sus deseos y quemar todos
los malos pensamientos y acciones que
quieran dejar atrás una tradición
centenaria en la que la actualidad
mundial y el no a la guerra también
tuvieron su lugar
gracias para acompañarnos en esta nueva
emisión de corresponsales nos damos cita
la próxima semana siga con más
información en france 24 y france 24
puntos